you're from uh the UCB right Upright
Citizens Brigade my my improv I came in
in New York and I I started with them I
was like one of their first students so
my teachers in improv were Amy po Matt
Walsh Matt besser and Ian Roberts wow so
I felt I felt blessed that I got to
learn from such unbelievably talented
people but you do it all so you do
improv you're doing these sketches what
do you like better acting and you also
do standup didn't you do I did I did
standup uh for a while when I when I was
on The Daily Show I shared an office
with John Oliver yeah and I used to make
him come down to the upright citizen
Brigade to do monologues for the ascat
show which is just a long form improv
show right and um and then he said all
right now you got to come with me and do
standup and I was like oh dude I suck at
standup I tried it I hated it they hate
me you know it just was because I I went
to the comic strip on the upper east uh
upper e side yeah and uh there was a a
comedian up there who was teaching the
classes the first thing I did when I got
to New York I took his class DF swindley
Sweden I don't know what his name is
he's the consumate comedy Professor
everybody knows who he is thef
swim but I went sometimes I'll go to a
show and I'll go and I'll listen to
Somebody the audience is roaring and
they go this is amazing well he's no DF
swimm I will say that well when I got to
New York I was on active duty in the
Marines and I had no idea how I was
going to do comedy and show business but
I or be an actor or a comedian which I
wanted to do I knew that was I wanted it
I wanted it I wanted I didn't know how
and the only thing I knew was I loved
storytelling comedians like uh Eddie
Murphy or you know um I I like the
storytelling yes and so that I thought
was that's if I do anything I'll be a
Storyteller uh type comedian and when I
got to this class um he was like no no
no no we do three jokes per minute setup
punch setup punch setup punch set up
punch so
DF it is and uh and so I was like all
right so I tried to do it his way I
hated it was kind of like putting on a
really uncomfortable shoe and then I
then I found the upright citizen Brigade
and I I was like oh this is this is what
I'm doing so that's so I let let go of
stand up but then when I was with John
he was like he made me go with him to
these clubs and and he was a bachelor I
was uh a a geographical Bachelor I mean
my family was on the west coast I was on
the east coast and a geographical
Bachelor just meaning you know I wasn't
if you're not the wife then you're not
married I mean I'm missing something I
don't know again that's you're teaching
us something that didn't we didn't know
are you single geographically
geographically do you see her and there
is no her 50 mile radius what are we
talking uh but then so I would go out
with John because we both didn't after
work uh I would I would walk home and
and that was it that was what I would do
because anything else was bad you know
if I if I if I went out I would spend
money uh or get in trouble so there was
no point of me going out right so when
when John was said let's go well because
New York's so great you can hit four or
five mics in a night you just jump in a
cab and go to the next we jump in a cab
go to the next go and I was able to
build a set and he kind of helped me
understand how to do that and and I was
very grateful so then I was able to
build a set and tour it for several
years and and I really enjoyed that that
was great but then I I I stopped doing
that when I got Fox NFL so see that M
what does that teach you just to work
really hard at something and then you're
done there is a Finish Line there is a
Finish Line don't let anybody tell stand
up you don't want to do standup anymore
you don't want to do stand up anymore no
I I would love to I just remember it
took me it took me a year maybe 14 to 15
months to build that set that 45 minutes
yeah and it was grinding grinding
grinding bu realize building a set is
hard and then when you people don't
realize I want to say to the people that
if you it could cost it could take you
almost a month to come up with a lot of
jokes that people don't realize that's
the toughest thing in the like they look
at people who are you know working on
our highways or manual lab andu man
labor people looking for cure for cancer
people working in Labs total
they don't realize that comedy
you could spend almost a year coming up
with like silly ideas and and and jokes
and
then what do you got to show for it like
Netflix special or something like that
really it's not worth it that's why if
you're even thinking of going in comedy
I would do hard labor yeah AB absolutely
grab a hammer and I I know right now all
the DF fans are saying what the you
talking about what are you what are you
talking about go see DF in New York and
and start building who is it who is it I
don't even know if I got the initials
right to be honest with you really you
the df's not right I don't know so let's
call it let's call it like it
is where did you learn
comedy um was so you're close to your
kids your kids are they fans uh yeah
well I think so I'm I'm fans of theirs I
think they're fans of
[Music]
mine